[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في حصاد الليله معكم عبد القادر
عياد في الوقت الذي يحدثكم فيه تقع واحداث
وتتفاعل اخرى في مناطق مختلفه من العالم
البدايه من
اوديسا جنوبي اوكرانيا تزامنا مع تحذيرات
غربيه من فرض روسيا حصارا بحريا على
الشواطئ الاوكرانيه
ثم من الخرطوم نتابع هذه الصور في نهايه
يوم شهد معارك محتذبه بين الجيش السوداني
وقوات الدعم السريع في مدن العاصمه الثلاث
وفي مواضيع الحصاد هذه الليله
هي اعقاب احتجاز قوه من الحرس الرئاسي في
النيجر للرئيس محمد بازو مصادر تقول
للجزيره ان قوات الخاصه وصلت الى العاصمه
النيابي لتحريره وتنديد افريقي واوروبي
وامريكي بالمحاوله الانقلابيه
ومطالبات دوليه بالافراج الفوري عنه
والحفاظ على المؤسسات الدستوريه في النيجر
على وقع تحذيرات غربيه متواليه من احتمال
طرد روسيا حصارا بحريا على اوكرانيا
القوات الاوكرانيه تحذر من لجوء موسكو
لضرب سفن بدنيه في البحر الاسود في اعقاب
مناورات صاروخيه روسيه وتوعد روسي بالرد
على الهجمات الاوكرانيه في القرن وموسكو
مدن الخرطوم مع الثلاث مسرح لمعارك ضاريه
بين الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع
قصف مدفعي للجيش على مواقع في ام درمان
والخرطوم بحري وقوه الدعم تتصدى لغارات
الجيش جنوبي الخرطوم وشرق النيل
في لقائنا اليومي قبل الحصاد كما جرت عليه
العاده ناقشنا معكم افاق نجاح روسيا في
استراتيجيتها الراميه لتوسيع نفوذها في
القاره الافريقيه وذلك تزامنا مع
استضافتها في مدينه
القمه الروسيه الافريقيه في نسختها
الثانيه باستطلاع ارائكم بشان هذا الموضوع
كنا قد طرحنا عليكم السؤال التالي ما هي
اسباب اهتمام روسيا بتوطيد الشركات مع
افريقيا جاءت اجاباتكم وجاءت نتائج
التصويت على الشكل التالي
24% قالوا ان السبب هو مجال بكسر عزلتها
الدوليه في حين ارجع 18% السبب الى بحث
روسيا عن اسواق بديله واخيرا صوت 58%
لصالح القول ان سببه هو مساحه نفوذ مهمه
لروسيا في ظل تنافس دوليه
هذا السؤال سيبقى مطروحا على منصاتنا
الرقميه ويمكنكم دخول صفحه التصويت عبر
مسح رمز كيو ار الظاهر على الشاشه
لقاؤنا على بنشاط الرقميه يتجدد يوميا
وتطرق خلال غول قضايا مستجده ومتفاعل
عربيا وكذلك دوليا
ثبتوا تتابعون في الحصاد ايضا
تواصل مكافحه حرائق الغابات في جزر
يونانيه مختلفه مع اشتداد موجه الحر
للاسبوع الثالث على التوالي
[موسيقى]
النيجر قالت مصادر للجزيره ان مجموعه
عسكريه من قوات النيجر الخاصه المتمركزه
في منطقه تيلابيري غربي النيجر وصلت
العاصمه وان قوات عسكريه تقف امام مبنى
التلفزيون الحكومي وتتمركز عده سيارات
عسكريه باسلحه متوسطه في الشارع الرئيسي
هذا وكان جنود من الحرس الرئاسي في النيجر
قد احتجزوا الرئيس محمد بازوم داخل القصر
الرئاسي وقالت الرئاسه في النيجر ان الجيش
جاهز لمهاجمه عناصر الحرس الرئاسي ان لم
يتراجعوا
يبدو اهل هذه البلاد معتادين على التوترات
في انظمه الحكم هكذا بدا محيط القصر
الرئاسي في عاصمه النيجر نيامي المؤكد من
اخبار حتى الان ان جنود من الحرس الرئاسي
احتجز الرئيس محمد بازون داخل القصر رغم
ذلك يصدر بيان من الرئاسه يصف ما يجري
بالقول ان الحرس بدا حركه مناهضه
للجمهوريه عبثا ففقد تصريح تقول الرئاسه
ايضا ان الجيش لم يدعم الحرس في تحركاته
بل على العكس البيان يؤكد بان في حال لم
يعني يتم اطلاق
لانه ممكن يكون هناك زحف عسكري او من
الجيش او من الطرق الوطني
في الساعات المقبله في حال يعني لم يتم
الوصول الى حل ملموس لهذه القضيه وهذا
الوضع هكذا تتجه الانظار الان الى الجيش
في البلاد موقفه قد يحسم الامر اما الى
انقلاب عسكري مكتمل الاركان ينتهي
بالاطاحه بالرئيس او الى محاوله لتنحيه
الرئيس سيفشلها الجيش ذلك امر اعتاد اهل
النيجر عليه اذ شاهدوا اربعه انقلابات
وعددا من المحاولات الفاشله منذ الاستقلال
عن فرنسا عام 60 من القرن الماضي الرئيس
الحالي نفسه كان منصبه مهددا بالخطر بعد
ساعات فقط من انتخابه عام 2021 لكن لا شيء
خارج سياقاته في تلك المنطقه مواقف
اقليميه ودوليه تعكس اهميه استقرار النيجر
للمحيطين به يدين الاتحاد ما وصفه بمحاوله
زعزعه الديمقراطيه في النيجر يقول رئيس
المفوضيه الافريقيه انما يجري هناك خيانه
ويحث الجنود على التوقف فورا اما المجموعه
الاقتصاديه لدول غرب افريقيا فتصف هؤلاء
الجنود بالمتامرين وتدعوهم الى اطلاق سراح
الرئيس هكذا تستنفر افريقيا للحفاظ على
استقرار النيجر احدى اكبر الدول في القاره
واحدى اكثر الدول العالم فقرا لكنها في
المقابل احدى اهم الدول في تصدير المواد
الخام وخصوصا اليورانيوم تلك ماده تشغل
المفاعلات النوويه التي تنتج طاقه تحتاجها
اقتصادات كبرى فكذلك ترسانات من القنابل
والصواريخ
مئات من المواطنين النيجر شاركوا في
مظاهرات مؤيده للرئيس البلاد محمد بازوم
المحتجزي داخل القصر الرئاسي وطالب
المتظاهرون الذين تجمعوا امام القصر
الرئاسي وسط العاصمه نيامي بالافراج
الفوري عن الرئيس ورد الحرس الرئاسي
باطلاق الرصاصي في الهواء بعد محاوله عدد
من المتظاهرين الاقتراب من اسوار القصر
ولم ترد اي معلومات حتى الان عن سقوط
ضحايا
الابيض احتجاز حرس الرئاسه في النيجر
للرئيس محمد بازوم وطالب بالافراج عنه
وقال منسق الاتصالات الاستراتيجيه في مجلس
الامن القومي الامريكي في مؤتمر صحفي ان
واشنطن تراقب الوضع في النيجر عن كثب
بشده احتجاز او تعطيل عمل حكومه النيجر
المنتخبه ديمقراطيا بقياده الرئيس بازون
ونحث بشكل خاص عناصر الحرس الرئاسي على
الافراج عن الرئيس بازون والامتناع عن
العنف نرحب بالبيانات والخطوات القويه
التي اتخذها المجتمع الاقتصادي لدول غرب
افريقيا والاتحاد الافريقي للدفاع عن
الديمقراطيه النيجر نراقب الوضع من كثب
لضمان سلامه مواطنين
ومن جهتها اكدت الخارجيه الفرنسيه في بيان
لها ادانتها الشديده لاي محاوله للاستيلاء
على السلطه عن طريق القوه وانها تضم صوتها
لنداء الاتحاد الافريقي والاكواس لاعاده
الاستقرار للمؤسسات الديمقراطيه بالنيجر
الامين العام للامم المتحده
ما وص
فه ولا السلطه بالقوه في النيجر وطالب
جميع الاطراف هناك بضبط النفس كما اعلن
المفوض الاعلى للسياسه الخارجيه والامن في
الاتحاد الاوروبي جوزيف بوريل عن اداره
الاتحاد محاوله زعزعه الاستقرار
والديمقراطيه في النيجر
هذا وكاله النيجر قد شهدت مظاهرات اعتراضا
على الوجود العسكري الفرنسي فيها ويثير
المشهد الحالي في النيجر مخاوف من تكرار
السيناريو الذي وقع في مالي ودول جوار
اخرى تفاصيل اكثر في التقرير التالي
ما يحدث الان في النيجر هل يكون نسخه لما
حدث سابقا في جارتها مالي بعد انحصار
الوجود الفرنسي لصالح دور روسي تمثله
مجموعه فاجنر بدايه فان النيجر ومالي
وتشاد وبوركينا فاسو وموريتانيا وتعرف
بمنطقه السحل الافريقي هي منطقه نفوذ
جيوسياسي فرنسي منذ عقود وغنيه بثروات مثل
الذهب والنفط واليورانيوم والفوسفاط جعلت
منها محطه تنافس دول عديده لفرنسا في
النيجر قاعده جويه في العاصمه النيامي
وفيها مقاتلات وطائرات مسيره ومروحيات
ويقدر عدد الجنود الفرنسيين فيها بالف
جندي في مالي صيفه عام 2020 شهدت البلاد
انقلابا عسكريا ورفض المجلس العسكري الذي
تقلد السلطه التنازل عنها ومع خروج
مظاهرات رافضه للوجود الفرنسي بدا وجود
مجموعه فاجنر يبدو واضحا للعيان بعد ان
كان مجرد حديث في تقارير اعلاميه وكان ذلك
بطلب من المجلس العسكري في اغسطس من عام
2022 قررت فرنسا الانسحاب من مالي واعادت
نشر نحو 400 جندي في النيجر وسط احتجاجات
رافضه للوجود الفرنسي وكان لافتا رفع
العلم الروسي فيها كما حدث في مظاهره مالي
الان يحتجز الرئيس محمد بازون في القصر
الرئاسي عاصمه النيجر ولا يعرف اتجاه
الامور ونتيجتها يؤخذ على الوجود العسكري
الفرنسي في دول الساحل عدم تحقيق اهدافه
وهي الحد من انتشار الجماعات المسلحه وضبط
الحاله الامنيه مقابل تمدد واضح لدور روسي
تمثله مجموعه فاجنر وهي تقوم بمهامه في
دول افريقيه اخرى مثل مالي وموزمبيق
ومدغشقر وافريقيا الوسطى وليبيا والسودان
ولابد من الاشاره اخيرا الى عامل مهم خارج
القاره الافريقيه هو تصريح قائد فاجنر ريف
جينيبر قبل ايام بانهم ومن بيلاروسيا
سيشدون الرحال نحو افريقيا
من وقشط معنى اسماعيل ولد الشيخ سيدي
المحلل المتخصص في الشان الافريقي اهلا بك
سيد اسماعيل
واريد منك كيف فهمت ما يجري في النيجر
لما اسمع السؤال جيدا سالتك عن تحليلك
وفهمك لما يجري في النيجر
اوكي اهلا بك يا اخي عبد القادر اهلا
وسهلا بمشاهدك الكرام شكرا للاستضافه على
الاستضافه الواقع انه فرضيه التمرد انتهت
لانه القائد الاعلى للقوات المسلحه اللي
هو رئيس الجمهوريه مصحوبا بوزير الداخليه
وزير الدفاع وهم في حاله اعتقال في
الاقامه الرئيسيه اللي يسموها هناك
فيلا الخضراء واضح كذلك انه القيادات
العليا يعني هي في حال التفاوض
وان هنالك نضج في تسيير الازمه من قبل
القاده الكبار اللي هم جنرالات الجنرال
عمر اللي هو قائد الحرس الجمهوري حتى الان
ليس هنالك جرحى ليست هنالك استخدام للقوه
فقط طلقات تحضيريه معنا انه ليس الامر ليس
تمردا وانما هو اعتقال لرئيس قد يفضي
الانقلاب طبيعه زي قيد الاركان النيجيري
وقائد الاستخبارات نيجيريا الى النيجر
والرئيس بناه الذي هو في الطريق بعدما بعد
مقيل مع الرئيس نيجيريا والرئيس الدوري او
الاكواس هذا يدل على انه هنالك احتمالان
ان هنالك انقلاب ينبغي ان يسلم به او خروج
امن
للمنفذين ولذلك سارعت الى البحث في شيء ما
بعثت برئيس دوله
مجاوره للنيجر يربطها بها انبوب انبوب
للغاز والكثير من مصالح الاقتصاديه وهذا
يدل على انه الليله لا تشبه البارحه معناه
انه لم تنضج الامور فيما بعد ولكن هنالك
شيئا كبيرا طيب سيحدث وعلى كل حال له
علاقه
بالتنحي او المخرج الامن للمقالبين ما
تفسير انه الى الان ليس هناك بيان واضح من
الجيش حتى ما نقل عن الجيش نقل عن طريق
القصر الرئاسي
انا اعتقد انه الجيش الجيش الضباط الكبار
بطبيعه طبيعه طبيعه تكوينهم يخشون القتال
ويخشون تاثيرات القتال ويخشون اطلاق النار
اكثر من المدنيين نفسهم ولذلك في استخدام
عمر الجنرال عمر اللي هو قائد الحرس
الجمهوري استخدامه لهذا الدرع البشري الذي
هو القائد اللي على القوات المسلحه كان
ذكيا وكان فعالا بحيث لا يستطيع لا تستطيع
القوات الخاصه القادمه من تلابيري والتي
انسحبت عن مبنى الاذاعه والتلفزيون لا
تستطيع المجازفه باطلاق النار لان روح
القائد في خطر معناه انه نحن هنا في تكتيك
وتكتيك مضاد ثم ان الرئيس نفسه لم لم
يخصص وقتا كافيا لمراجعه قادته العسكريين
لانه الجنرال عمر هو ابن عم يوسف ويوسف
تدخل كثيرا لو الرئيس السابق تدخل كثيرا
بالاشهر الماضيه في تسيير الشؤ الرئاسه هو
ضايق خلفه في النفول وخلفه ايضا يعني لديه
يعني الكثير من القاده العسكريين يطعنون
في كونه من الاقليه العربيه وعبروا عن ذلك
عن طريق الساسه ايام الترشحه وبالتالي
اعتقد انه هنالك نوع من محاوله استغلال
الوقت لكي لا يكون
في ساحه السياسيه والعسكريه حتى يكبر
وبالتالي هل نحن امام موقف وان كان غير
معلن حتى الان من قبل الجيش ام ان هناك
اكثر من راي داخل هذه المؤسسه عن الجيش
اكيد هنالك اكثر من راي لانه بازون بطبيعه
الحال هو داهيه استاذ فلسفه ونقابي سابق
ورجل بدوي ولا اعتقد انه سيكون لقمه سائغه
للحرس الرئاسي لديه قوات خاصه ولاكثر من
عشر كتائب وهي متحركه ولديها القدره على
التحرك وتبعد في معظمها 200 كيلومتر من
يمه وبالتالي المواجهه قادمه لا محاله الا
اذا وجد مخرج امن عند وصول الوساطه
الافريقيه الليله اللي هو الرئيس التالو
اعتقد انه هنالك امور تدار بحكمه والعقل
العقل موضوع على الواجهه الا ما كان من
الدرع البشري بالرئيس هذا هو وحده الحرس
الرئاسي لانه ليس لديه انتشار يكفي خارج
العاصمه وبالتالي فليس في مامن من
المواجهه ماذا عن البعد الخارجي فيما يجري
سواء
بالتاثير او التاثر
[موسيقى]
اسماعيل ولد الشيخ يا سيدي المحلل المتخصص
في الشهاده الافريقي شكرا جزيلا لك
[موسيقى]
في تطورات حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا وما
توالي التحذيرات الغربيه من فرض روسيا
حصارا بحريا على الشواطئ الاوكرانيه عقب
مناورات صاروخيه للاسطول الروسي في الجزء
الشمالي الغربي من البحر الاسود قالت
قياده العمليات الجنوبيه الاوكرانيه ان
روسيا ربما تلجا الى الاستفزاز بضرب السفن
المدنيه في البحر الاسود وتلقي باللوم على
اوكرانيا ورجحت قياده العمليات الجنوبيه
ان تستخدم موسكو شبه جزيره القرم للاعتداء
على السفن المدنيه
قالت الاستخبارات البريطانيه ان اسطول
البحر الاسود الروسي عدل مواقع تمركزه منذ
انسحاب روسيا من مبادره حبوب البحر الاسود
استعدادا لفرض حصار على اوكرانيا واضافت
الاستخبارات البريطانيه ان روسيا تنشر
ونشرت السفينه سيرجياي كوتوف في جنوب
البحر الاسود ونفذت دوريات في ممر الشحن
بين مضيق البوسفور واوديستارت واوضحت
الاستخبارات البريطانيه ان من المحتمل ان
تشكل السفينه الروسيه جزءا من مجموعه مهام
الاعتراض السفن التجاريه التي تعتقد موسكو
انها متجهه الى اوكرانيا
وحضرت المتحدثه باسم قياده عمليات الجنوب
اوكرانيه نتاليا ومن يوم من وجود احتمال
قيام روسيا باستهداف سفن مدنيه في البحر
الاسود او تنفيذ عمليات استفزازيه في
المنطقه
[موسيقى]
واغلاق مسارات السفن ومحاولاتهم السيطره
على سوق الحبوب ورغباتهم باظهار سيطرتهم
في البحر الاسود كل هوارده يمكن ان ينفذ
الروس عمليه بمثابه هجوم على السفينه ترفع
علما اجنبيا في البحر الاسود او ان تفتعل
هجوما ما ثم تتهم اوكرانيا بالقيام بذلك
او حتى ان ترسل روسيا سفينه تحمل اي عالم
اجنبي وتهاجمها لخلق ازمه في البحر الاسود
وفي المقابل قالت المتحدثه باسم وزاره
الخارجيه الروسيه
تحتفظ بحق اتخاذ اجراءات رد صارمه على ما
وصفته بالهجمات الارهابيه الاوكرانيه على
القرن وعلى موسكو
بدا يستخدم على ارض المعركه القنابل
العنقوديه التي زودته بها الولايه المتحده
هذه القنابل استهدفت سياره الصحفيين روس
حيث قتل مراسل عسكري اخرون بجروح وعلى
الرغم من تحضير المجتمع الدولي ورؤساء
عشرات الدول والمنظمات الدوليه المعنيه من
تزويدك بالقنابل العنقوديه ما يعد خرقا
للمعايير الانسانيه اقدمت الولايات
المتحده على ذلك ولن يرضعها الا رد قاسي
وملائم هجمته اوكرانيا التي تستهدف البنى
التحتيه الروسيه مدعومه من الولايات
المتحده وبريطانيا والحديث عن السلام يبدا
بوقف ضخ الاسلحه في اوكرانيا
الامين العام
خلال جلسه اجتماع مجلس النيتو اوكرانيا في
بروكسل دان انسحاب روسيا بالاتفاق الحبوب
وما وصفه باستخدام موسكو الجوع سلاحا
وتصرفاته الخطيره في البحر الاسود وبحث
اجتماع مجلس النيتو اوكرانيا قضيه انسحاب
روسيا من اتفاق الحبوب والتصعيد العسكري
الروسي ضد اوديسا واستهدافها الموانئ
ومنشات البنيه التحتيه الاوكرانيه
الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي وابدا بضيف
السيد بابل للمحاوله فهم ما هي حسابات
موسكو بقيامها بهذه المناورات التي في
البحر الاسود التي وصفت من قبل حلف الاطلس
بانها مناورات خطيره وخطيره جدا وبانها
مناورات تجويع للعالم
ان الحسابات الروسيه واضحه فروسيا
تريد كما قال ان تواصل العمل بصفقه الحبوب
ولكن بشروطها الخاصه فروسيا تريد
لمصرف الدوله
الروسي ان يستخدم ان يسمح له باستخدام
نظام السويفت للحصول على التحويلات
الاموال لدقائق البيعه الاسمده والحبوب
الروسيه كما ان روسيا تريد ان تستانف
تصدير غاز الامونيا الذي تنتجه وايضا
تستانف نقل نقله عن طريق خطا انابيب خاص
عن طريق اوديسا ومنها الى اسواق العالميه
هذه هي
الرغبات الرئيسيه التي طالبت بها روسيا
وان روسيا تحاول تحقيق كل هذا باستخدام
لعبه القوه التقليديه
ليس فقط بانهاء او الانسحاب الصفقه الحبوب
ايضا باضافه اضافه الى مهاجمه المشعات
الموانع الاوكرانيه كانت
لتصدير الحبوب وايضا السائده صوامع الحبوب
داسيا وفي موانئها الاخرى بما بركه
موانع على نهر الدانوب فحاليا الكثير من
هذه الحبوب يمر عن طريق نهر الدانوب
وبالروسيا تقول لهم اذا لم توافقوا على
شروطنا فاننا سلحكم حقيقه ضررا ضررا كبيرا
بالصادرات الاوكرانيه اما اذا وافقتم
اسال ضيفي من كيف السيد في حال
نفذت روسيا ما تقوم به الان من هذا الحصار
وكذلك استهداف هذه المنشات للحبوب في
اوكرانيا ماذا تستطيع ان تفعل حيال هذه
الاجراءات الروسيه
هذا سؤال وجيه للغايه يمكننا ان نتحدث عن
مسالتين منفصلتين هنا اولا احتمال قيام
البحريه الروسيه
بتنفيذ هذه التهديدات الموجهه الى
اوكرانيا وهذا مشكوك به بالنسبه الى
استهداف
السفن واوكرانيا اعلنت في الحقيقه انها
سوف تعتبر اي سفينه تتجه باتجاه الموانئ
الروسيه على انها تحمل معدات عسكريه
وبالتالي هذا تصعيد على الارجح لم تتوقعه
روسيا بالنسبه الى تصدير اوكرانيا لحبوبها
وامكانيه القيام بذلك نعم ان روسيا قامت
بقصف الموانئ والبنى التحتيه الاوكرانيه
التي تخزن
الحبوب ولكن هناك طرق اخرى يمكن النظر بها
من خلال سكك الحديد للوصول الى الاسواق في
كل انحاء العالم اذا روسيا لا يمكنها ان
تمنع اوكرانيا من تصدير حبوبها الى اوروبا
الى ضيفي وايضا تتابع ردود الفعل من
اوكرانيا
تقلد تحذر ولكن تقلل من هذه من قيمه هذه
الاجراءات من قبل موسكو وبل وتهدد بانه
ربما يتم التعامل بالمثل وبالتالي الى اي
مدى موسكو تدرس جميع عواقب هذه الخطوات
الروسيه
يتعلق بالتهديدات ضد
السفن في البحر الاسود انها
خطيره في لانها فعلا
ستبعد
تعطى الشركات الشركات التامين الاعتياديه
على السفن لانها لن تقدم تامين على اي
سفينه تبحر في البحر الاسود وهذا السيء
لروسيا وايضا لاوكرانيا لكنه اسوا لروسيا
تعتمد على البحر الاسود في في سفنها اكثر
ما تفعل اوكرانيا ولكن لحسن الحظ هناك امل
في موسكا بان لعبه القوه هذه
الى الضغط ليس على اوكرانيا فقط بل على
الغرب ايضا
للتوصل الى لموافقه على الطلبات والشروط
الروسيه حاليا في الشهر العالم كله شرقا
وغربا يطلعون الى ما سيحصل في المحادثات
التاليه القادمه بين الرئيس التركي
اردوغان والرئيس فلاديمير بوتين روسيا
الذي لديه برنامج للسفر الى تركيا في شهر
اغسطس عام
وهناك مال لدينا هنا بان ربما السيد
اردوغان سوف
يفعل ما حقيقه سابقا ان يخرج الارنب من
القبعه بمعنى توصل الى صيغتين تسمح
باستئناف شحنات الحبوب لانهم من حيث
المبدا الجميع يريدون ذلك ولكن هناك عده
امور مرتبطه بذلك وهناك ايضا طبعا خطر انه
ربما تحصل بعض الهجمات في البحر الاسود
يمكن تؤدي الى تصعيد في الموقف وهذا
وبالتالي هذه لعبه خطيره والواقع لكن في
موسكو يعتقدون بانهم يمكن ان يؤدي حصول
على نتيجه جيدا
جزء من المطالب الروسيه والتي لاجلها قامت
بهذه الخطوات مثل ما يتعلق بالنظام سويفت
وايضا استمعت الى ضيفي يقول بان جزء من
هذا الفعل الروسي يتعلق بالضغط على حلفاء
اوكرانيا من اجل تلبيه هذه المطالب لروسيا
هل تتعرض اوكرانيا لضغوط من قبل حلفائها
حتى تكون اكثر مرونه
نعم هناك تحديات مرتبطه بهذا الموضوع ولكن
هذا الامر يتوقف على الشركاء الغربيين وما
اذا كانوا فهموا في نهايه المطاف انه في
كل مره نحاول فيها ان نلبي المطالب
الروسيه سوف نشهد مطالب اضافيه وبشكل
متكرر ان روسيا تطلب وتتصرف على طريقه
المافيا تستحدث المشكله تخلق هذه المشكله
وتاتيك بالحل اذا اذا ما قام الغرب بالرد
بالايجاب ازاء هذه المطالب سوف يكون هناك
مطالب اضافيه وهذه من بين الدروس
المستخلصه في العلاقه مع الاتحاد الروسي
طبعا بكل تاكيد يتعين علينا ان ننتظر لنرى
ما اذا سوف نشهد ايضا من الجانب الاخر لا
اتحدث فقط عن اوكرانيا هنا بل ايضا عن
موقف الصين وموقف تركيا بالاضافه الى
الهجمات الاخيره التي استهدفت نهر الدانوب
وهذا امر
جديد وهو قريب من الحدود الرومانيه
وبالتالي من حدود حلف شمال الاطلسي ان
حريه الملاحه البحريه في البحر الاسود
غرقت من قبل الروس
وهذا التصعيد هو خطر من قبل روسيا
مساعد وزير الدفاع الاوكراني السابق شكرا
لك وكذلك لضيفي من موسكو بابل الخبير
العسكري والاستراتيجي
[موسيقى]
قالت مصادر محليه للجزيره الى الطائرات
الحربيه التابعه للجيش السوداني قصفت عددا
من المواقع قوه الدعم السريع جنوبي
الخرطوم وفي شرق النيل وذكرت المصادر ان
الجيش السوداني قصف بالمدفعيه ايضا مواقع
للدعم السريع جنوب ضاحيه الصالحه جنوبيه
ام درمان وحي كافوري في الخرطوم بحري
وقالت مصادر وقال مراسله الجزيره ان اصوات
اشتباكات بالاسلحه الثقيله تسمع منذ
الصباح في شمال ام درمان وتشاهد اعمده
دخان تتصاعد وسط المدينه واضاف مراسل
الجزيره ان الطائرات الحربيه للجيش ظلت
تحلق منذ الصباح في سماء مدن العاصمه
السودانيه الخرطوم والخرطوم بحري وام
درمان بالتزامن مع اطلاق نار من المضادات
الارضيه لقوات الدعم السريع لتصدي
للتصدي للغارات الجويه
[موسيقى]
عقد رئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان اجتماعا
في انقره مع الرئيس الفلسطيني محمود عباس
ورئيسي المكتب السياسي لحركه حماس اسماعيل
هنيه وجدد الرئيس التركي خلال الاجتماع
رفض بلاده للحصار المفروض على قطاع غزه
ونقلت وكاله الاناضول ان عباس وهنيه اتفق
على تكاتف الجهود الوطنيه لمكافحه المخاطر
التي تتعرض لها القضيه الفلسطينيه خصوصا
في الضفه الغربيه والقدس
قالت مصادر للجزيره ان الرئيس الفلسطيني
طرح على رئيس المكتب السياسي لحركه حماس
خلال لقائهما في انقره رؤيه سياسيه
سيعرضها في مؤتمر الامناء العامين في
القاهره واضافت المصادر ان الرئيس عباس
اكد لجنيه ان الخطه تستند للشرعيه الدوليه
وان منظمه التحرير ممثل وحيد وعلى الجميع
الانضمام لها واشارت المصادر الى ان
الرئيس عباس شدد التزامه بخيار المقاومه
السلميه وانه لا سلاح غير سلاح السلطه في
المقابل اكدت المصادر على ان هنيه ابلغ
عباس تبني حماس خيار المقاومه بكافه
اشكالها وعدم قبولها بصيغه الالتزام
بالشرعيه الدوليه كما اكدها لي ان حماس
تستهدف الاحتلال وغير معنيه بمهاجمه
السلطه او اسقاطها ووفق المصادر فقد رفض
الرئيس الفلسطيني طلب هنيه الافراج العاجل
عن المعتقلين السياسيين وربط ذلك بالحوار
في اجتماع الامناء العام ين بالقاهره
نهايه الشهر وقد طلبت الجبهه الشعبيه
الرئيس عباس توفير الاجواء الايجابيه لعقد
اجتماع الامناء العامين من خلال اطلاق
سراح المعتقلين لانجاح الاجتماع والحيلوله
دون فشله وقالت الجبهه ان عدم الاستجابه
لمطالب الافراج عن المعتقلين وصفا لوصفه
لافشال اجتماعي الامناء
شيع سكان مدينه نابلس بالضفه الغربيه
جثمانه الشاب محمد ندى الذي استشهد متاثرا
بجروح اصيب بها خلال اقتحام جيش الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي مخيم العين وردد المشيعون
هتافات غاضبه تردد بجرائم الاحتلال بحق
الفلسطينيين وكان الجيش الاسرائيلي قد
اقتحم المخيم لاعتقال الشاب نور بسيوني من
منزله بذريعه تخطيطه لهجمات ضد اهداف
اسرائيليه كما اصيبت فتاه برضوض بعد ان
صدمتها عربه عسكريه اسرائيليه خلال
العمليه
هذا وقد دانه وزاره الخارجيه الفلسطينيه
ما وصفته بجريمه اعدام الشاب محمد ندى
التي ارتكبتها الاحتلال في مخيم العين
بنابلس واعتبرت الوزاره ان ما قامت به
اسرائيل اليوم يرقى الى جريمه حرب وجريمه
ضد الانسانيه من جانبه قال الناطق باسم
حركه حماس ان الجيش الاسرائيلي ارتكب
جريمه جديده بقتله الشهيد ندى
قال خبراء حقوق الانسان التابعون للامم
المتحده ان ضم اسرائيل المستمر لاجزاء من
الاراضي الفلسطينيه يشير الى احتمال سعيها
لضم كامل هذه الاراضي في انتهاك للقانون
الدولي واعتبر الخبراء في بيان ان توطيد
نظام الفصل العنصري هو نتيجه حتميه لمثل
هذا النظام
عنف وحشي وتوطيد لنظام فصل عنصري ومعايير
مزدوجه وانتهاكات للقانون الدولي اتهامات
مباشره للسلطات الاسرائيليه والمتهم هم
خبراء حقوق الانسان في الامم المتحده
استمرار محاولات الضم الاسرائيلي للاراضي
الفلسطينيه المحتله يزيد الضغط على موقف
المجتمع الدولي في ظل انتهاك اسرائيلي
ومنهج للقانون هكذا تحدث خبراء امم
المتحده دعينا الى انهاء ضم اسرائيل للضفه
الغربيه المحتله بما في ذلك القدس الشرقيه
فضم الاراضي او الاستيلاء عليها باستخدام
القوه او التهديد محظور بشكل قاطع بموجب
القانون الدولي ويشكل جريمه تدخل في
اختصاص المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه وتهديدا
للسلم والامن الدوليين وفق تقرير الخبراء
الدوليين بيان الامم المتحده اوضح ان
اسرائيل سعت باصرار الى ضم اجزاء كثيره من
الاراضي الفلسطينيه المحتله فعلى مدى
العقود الخمسه الماضيه صدقت اسرائيل على
مصادره الاراضي والموارد الفلسطينيه مما
ادى الى انشاء اكثر من 750 مستوطنه تضم
اكثر من 750 الف مستوطن اسرائيلي خبراء
حقوق الانسان التابعون للامم المتحده
خلصوا الى ان الفلسطينيين يخضعون للحكم
العسكري في ظل هذه الاوضاع بينما يتمتع
المستوطنون بحقوق مدنيه وسياسيه على
الاراضي الفلسطينيه وهو الوضع الذي وصفه
بالنتيجه الحتميه لسياسه توطط نظام الفصل
العنصري وفي خضم انكباب الهيئات الدوليه
على محاولات حل النزاعات في العالم يقول
خبراء الامم المتحده ان ضم اسرائيل
للاراضي الفلسطينيه المحتله محجوب بالخطاب
السياسي والمناقشات والمفاوضات التي تقوم
في نهايه المطاف على معايير مزدوجه حسب
تعبيرهم مضيفين انما وصفوه بالانفاذ
الانتقائي للقانون الدولي يقوض اسس ميثاق
الامم المتحده
والوعده بعالميه حقوق الانسان الدوليه
مسلسل حوادث قتل الفلسطينيين اثار قلق
خبراء الامم المتحده اذ اشاروا الى تصاعد
نطاق ووحشيه العنف الذي يمارس ضد
الفلسطينيين في انتهاك واضح للحق في
الحياه ودعوا اسرائيل الى انهاء هذه
الانتهاكات على الفور معربين عن خشيتهم من
استمرار دوامه العنف ما لم تستعد اولويه
القانون الدولي كاساس للامن والسلم
اعلن الدوله قطر انها قدمت مذكره الى
محكمه العدل الدولي بشان التابعات
القانونيه الناجمه عن ممارساته الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي واكد الدوله قطر في مذاكرتها
ان الاحتلال الاسرائيلي يرقى الى كونه
نظام فصل عنصري غير شرعي كما طالبت دوله
قطر محكمه العدل الدوليه بان تخلص الى
ضروره انهاء الاحتلال الاسرائيلي وتبعاته
وتعويض ضحاياه
[موسيقى]
تستضيف مدينه غدا الخميس القمه الروسيه
الافريقيه الثانيه بمشاركه معظم قاده
الدول الافريقيه وتعول موسكو على نجاحها
في ضوء استراتيجيه توسيع نفوذ يتهدد
ويتجدد لها في القاره الافريقيه هذا وكانت
القمه الروسيه الافريقيه الاولى قد عقدت
عام 2019 في سوتشي
جامعه الصداقه بين الشعوب في موسكو تعود
شهرتها الى الحقبه السوفيتيه من هذه
الجامعه التي تحمل اسم رئيس وزراء الكونغو
السابق باتريوس تخرج الاف الطلاب من دول
العالم الثالث معظمهم من القاره الافريقيه
ليساعد بلادهم على النمو لتصبح اكثر قوه
على الساحه الدوليه
عادت السلطات الروسيه مؤخرا اسم باتريس
لجامعه الصداقه بعد ازاله الاسم عقب
انهيار الاتحاد السوفيتي اعاده تبدو رمزيه
بالمعنى السياسي تتزامن مع عوده موسكو
القويه الى القاره السمراء ارتباط هذا
الاسم اسم باتريس
بالجامعه بيعطي دفعه قويه
لتعزيز والتطوير العلاقات
على المستوى العلمي والثقافي
والاقتصادي بين روسيا
والقاره الافريقيه
تعود علاقات موسكو مع افريقيا الى
خمسينيات القرن العشرين حيث دعم السوفييت
حركات التحرر الوطني الافريقيه ضد
الاستعمار الاوروبي والانظمه التي انتهجت
اليسارى في بعض الدول افريقيا
تراجع نفوذ موسكو في افريقيا بعد انهيار
الاتحاد السوفيتي لتعود روسيا مجددا الى
القاره الافريقيه من بوابه شركات عسكريه
خاصه ومكافحه الارهاب وعلاقات اقتصاديه
سياسيه واسعه
ونظمت اول قمه روسيه افريقيه عام 2019
شارك فيها معظم قاده القاره
في سانت فوترسبورغ تلتهم القمه الروسيه
الافريقيه الثانيه بظروف دوليه معقده
مورست خلالها الضغوط غربيه كبيره على
الدوله المضيفه والضيوف
لدى افريقيا من الامكانات ثم يجعلها قوه
مؤثره ولتحقيق ذلك تحتاج تنميه اقتصاديه
وهذا ممكن بانهاء الهيمنه الغربيه وتطوير
صناعه الطاقه وتحقيق الامن وهنا يبرز
الدور الروسي تعول روسيا كثيرا على نجاح
قمه بطرسبورغ بتوسيع نفوذها في افريقيا
وتشكيل عالم متعدد الاقطاب يكون فيه
للقارات السمراء كما تقول دور بارز
عاش وابدع وقتل شاعر روسيا الشهير الكسندر
بوشكين ربما كثر لا يعرفون ان بوشكين من
اصول افريقيه جاء جده الى روسيا من
اريتريا
رمزيه جديده يمكن ان تضافها الى اجواء
القمه الروسيه الافريقيه
زاور شوجا الجزيره
[موسيقى]
في تداعيات حرائق الغابات الناجمه عن
الارتفاع القياسي لدرجه الحراره عالميا
تواصل فرق والاطفاء اليونانيه محاوله
اخماد حرائق الغابات في جزر رودس وكورفو
وايليا مع تسجيل تراجع اجمالي في المساحه
التي تتاثر بها وتسببت الحرائق المستمره
للاسبوع الثاني بوفاه ثلاثه اشخاص بينهم
طيران خلال عمليه الاطفاء كما تم اجلاء
الاف السياح
[تصفيق]
موجه حر وجفاف ورياح في اليونان
التهمت النيران الاف الهكتارات في جزيره
رودس
[موسيقى]
فقرر الاهالي محاصرتها قبل ان تحاصره
شكلوا فرقا لمساعده طواقم الدفاع المدني
علينا ان نفعل كل شيء بانفسنا نحن الاهالي
ومعنا المتطوعون هذا بلدنا لا يمكننا ان
نثق بالحكومه
لكن هذا يحدث منذ سنوات اليس كذلك
نعم لقد كبرت مع النيران هذا امر محزن
انا محطم انا حزين جدا غاباتنا وجزيرتنا
انتهت
ضاع كل ما يملكه ديمتريوس حملت الرياح
السنه لهاب فاحرقت المطعم والمزرع خلال
دقائق تحول تعب حياته الى رماد
هذا المطعم عمره 32 عاما بدانا من الصفر
وهذا العام حققنا ارباحا لكن النيران دمرت
كل شيء
وفي الشارع تحطمت المرافق العامه وانقطع
التيار الكهربائي
نحاول اصلاح اعمده الكهرباء الامور تسير
ببطء لكن لو تحل الناس بالصبر فسيكون كل
شيء على ما يرام
استخدمت مياه البحر ووسائل اخرى لاخماد
النيران وجاء الطائرات من دول صديقه لهذا
الغرض غادر 20 الف سائح الجزيره لكن ضياع
عطله هؤلاء السياح يهون امام ماساه
الاهالي الذين يرون جزيرتهم تحترق
[موسيقى]
وتشتعل احيانا منذ اكثر من اسبوع هي حرب
مع النار كما وصفها رئيس الوزراء اليوناني
حرب طويله تلحق ضررا كبيرا بالتنوع الحيوي
الغني لهذه الجزيره محمد المدهون الجزيره
من جزيره رودوس اليونانيه
[موسيقى]
فقره المتابعه لحصادها الليله نقف فيها
على وضع الاغاثه الغذائيه العالميه بعد
اشهر من تحذيره الامم المتحده بان عام
2023 سيكون من اشد الاعوام قسوه على مستحق
الاعانه الغذائيه من الفقراء واللاجئين
عبر العالم فكيف اصبح المشهد بعد ان اضيف
اليه انسحاب روسيا اخيرا الى اتفاق تصدير
الحبوب في شهر ديسمبر الماضي قالت الامم
المتحده ان
333 مليون شخص في 68 بلدا سيحتاجون الى
مساعدات انسانيه خلال عام 2023 بزياده نحو
65 مليون شخص عن العام الفارض وتمتد تلك
الاحتجاج الاحتياجات من باكستان
وافغانستان
وبنغلاديش وسريلانكا مرورا بسوريا واليمن
ولبنان وصولا الى الكونغو واثيوبيا والص
والسودان وغيرها في القاره الافريقيه بسبب
الجفاف والفيضانات المدمره وجائحه كورونا
وحرب روسيا على اوكرانيا مؤخرا من اولئك
المحتاجين قالت المنظمه الدوليه ان 200
واثنين 222 مليون شخص على الاقل في 53
دوله سيواجهون انعداما حادا للامن الغذائي
عام 2023 اي هذه السنه كما يواجه 45 مليون
خمسه واربعون مليون شخص في 37 بلدا خطر قد
يصل الى المجاعه بينما تتراجع قدره وكاله
الاغاثه على الاستجابه للاحتياجات العاجله
والازمه توشيك ان تاخذ منعطفا جديدا بعد
انسحاب موسكو من اتفاق تصدير الحبوب عبر
البحر الاسود حيث تعتبر روسيا واوكرانيا
مصدرا مصدران رئيسيان
للاحتياجات العالميه من الحبوب هذا وقد
حذر ص النقد الدولي من ان انهيار الاتفاق
قد يرفع اسعار الحبوب نحو خمسه عشر في
المئه عن الاسعار الحاليه وهي مرتفعه اصلا
شبح البطون الخاويه والاجساد الهزيله
والاجساد الهزيله الذي يخيم على العالم
بسبب انعدام الامن الغذائي لا يمكن تفاديه
او الحد منه على الاقل وفق الامم المتحده
الا بالتزام الدول المانحه توفير
الاحتياجات الماليه العاجله والضخمه
فالتكلفه التقديريه للاستجابه الانسانيه
تبلغ في العام الحالي اكثر من خمسه او
خمسين مليار دولار وهو ما يمثل زياده
بنسبه خمسه وعشرين في المئه مقارنه بالعام
السابق وفي الشهر الماضي طالبت لجنه
الانقاذ الدوليه بتوفير اكثر من ثلاثه
مليارات دولار
بشكل عاجل لمساعده نحو 25 مليون سوداني
يحتاجون المعونه جراء المعارك ابتداء من
اغسطس المقبل وبسبب نقص التمويل قرر
برنامج الغذاء العالمي خفض المنحه الماليه
للاجئين السوريين في الاردن الى 21 دولار
شهريا بعد ان كانت اثنين وثلاثين دولارا
كما يتدهور الوضع المعيشي لملايين
السوريين في شمال البلاد بعد ان استخدمت
روسيا الفيتو ضد تجديد عمليه ادخال
المساعدات الى تلك المناطق وفق اليه
تديرها الامم المتحده عن هذا الملف معنا
من عمان الرئيس والمدير التنفيذي للجنه
الانقاذ الدوليه ووزيل الخارجيه البريطاني
السابق السيد ديفيد اهلا بك في تقريركم
السابق في شهر ديسمبر الماضي وصفتم وقدرتم
بان الوضع سيكون سودويا
في العالم بالنسبه لموضوع التغذيه
والاغاثه الان بانسحاب روسيا وكذلك ربما
يتاثر ايضا الجانب الاخرى فيما يتعلق
بتصدير الحبوب كيف تصفون وتقدرون الوضع
عقب هذه التطورات
ان القرار الروسي الذي شرحتموه اولا
القرار الاول فرض او استعمال حق النقد
بالنسبه الى سوريا وثانيا الانسحاب من
مبادره الحبوب في البحر الاسود
وصفات كانهما صفعه
للمنظومه الدوليه
وعقابا للاشخاص الذين هم بامس الحاجه ان
لجنه الانقاذ الدوليه تعمل في المناطق
الساخنه التي اشرتم اليها ونحن نرى ان
النزاع ليس فقط هو المشكله باضافه الى
المناخ ولكن ايضا هناك تبعات على مستوى
الاسعار اسعار الطاقه واسعار الغذاء
وبالتالي نعم ان الوضع يتفاقم بسبب القرار
الذي
شرحتموه ويطرح سؤال بالنسبه الى الدول
من الخليج الى العالم الغربي ما الذي يجب
القيام به وكيفيه التوصل الى حلول مواجهه
الوضع الذي وصفتموه وهذا سؤال ايضا لك سيد
هل لديكم
تصور ما حيال هذه التطورات حتى الان رب
تقديرات بان اسعار الحبوب قد ترتفع باكثر
من 15% وهي اصلا اسعار مرتفعه وبالتالي
توقع بنتائج كارثيه قد تؤدي الى الجوع في
بعض الدول هل هناك تصور لحلول المال
لبدائل الماء
ان ازمه المجاعه ليست في الافق فقط هي هنا
الان نحن لا نتحدث عن شيء في المستقبل هو
واقع ل 30 مليون او اربعين مليون من البشر
يعانون من ازمه غذاء حاده ونحن بحاجه الى
ثلاثه امور اساسيه بشكل ملح انتم على حق
انتم تتحدثون عن ارتفاع اسعار الغذاء وعدم
قدره الناس الذين يعتمدون على المساعدات
الحصول عليها اولا مجهود برنامج الاغذيه
العالميه بالاضافه الى المنظمات الاخرى
العالميه التي تتعامل مع هذه الازمه هي
بحاجه الى تمويل مناسب لانه الان برنامج
الاغذيه العالميه يقطع التمويل فيه عوضا
عن زيادته ثانيا المساعدات الانسانيه يجب
ان ترقى الى المستوى الذي في الازمه
الاوكرانيه 85% من المطالب المرتبطه
باوكرانيا تم تربيتها ولكن في لبنان 12%
لذلك نحن بحاجه الى الدعوه دول العالم
للاطلاع بمسؤولياتها المباشره وصولا الى
حل
لمواجهه هذه الارقام التي شاهدناها اذا
نحن بحاجه الى تقديم قيمه مقابل المال
بشكل افضل ونود ان نرى هذا العمل عوضا عن
20% من ذلك اذا الارقام هي اعلى بكثير
وثالثا على الامد البعيد هناك حاجه
لمعالجه جذور الازمه الافلات من العقاب
منع عمل المنظمات الانسانيه الانسحاب من
اتفاقيه الحبوب اذا هذا الافلات من العقاب
يجب ان يواجه
بتحميد المسؤوليات وهذه الاجنده بعيده
الامل انتم في عمان فيما يتعلق باللاجئين
السوريين وقرار سيتخذ قريبا في تخفيض
المنحه الممنوحه للاجئين السوريين وهي في
الاصل منحه قليله بالنظر لتحديات المعيشيه
ايضا ماذا عن هذا التخفيض ماذا عن تمويل
الصندوق لتمويل كل هؤلاء اللاجئين
لقد كنت في لبنان منذ ثلاثه ايام او
لثلاثه ايام وفي الاردن ليومين نتحدث عن
بلدين
يتحملان
المسؤوليه بشكل كبير باستضافه او باستضافه
اللاجئين باضافه الى تركيا وبلدان مثلي
لبنان والاردن لا يحصلون على مساعدات
مناسبه من المنظومه الدوليه هناك اولويتان
بالنسبه الى منظمات المساعده الدوليه التي
تعمل مع
جانب اللبناني والاردني نحن بحاجه الى
تلبيه حاجات
اللاجئين السوريين ولكن ايضا
الجماعات الاقل حذوه في لبنان والاردن
ولذلك هناك اجتماع نقوم في خلالها على
مستوى اللجنه
بالتطرق الى احتياجات السوريين
واللبنانيين والاردنيين من خلال برامج
الطفوله او برامج الغذاء لتلبيه احتياجات
هؤلاء انها لحظه مهمه
للتوحد بين الناس والحكومات في المنطقه
بالاضافه الى المنظومه الدوليه ونحن نمثل
الجهه المستقله غير الحكوميه غير السياسيه
ونحن نعمل بشكل غير منحاز في هذه المساله
ولذلك من الاهميه بمكان ان ننسج الشركات
على المستوى المحلي وفي حالات متعدده
مضينا قدما في عملنا بطريقه مهمه
الى استعمال روسيا لحق النقد الفيتو حياله
دخول المساعدات الى الشمال السوري
كيفما هو تصوركم للتعامل مع ايضا مع هذه
الخطوه فيما يتعلق بالجانب الاغاثي
والانسان في هذه المناطق المتضرره والتي
تعاني انسانيه
اليوم الى قاده
اللجنه في شمال غرب سوريا وشمال شرق سوريا
نتحدث عن اشخاص يعملون لغايه الانسانيه من
اجل تقديم المبادرات الاقتصاديه
والاجتماعيات للناس الذين هم ضحايا الحرب
في داخل بلدهم مدحايا ضحايا لهذا النزاع
في داخل بلدهم اعتقد وانهم الاهميه في
مكان ان نتذكر انه في شمال غرب سوريا نحن
في فتره ما بعد الزلزال الذي ضرب تلك
المنطقه وهناك هزات ارتداديه استمرت لفتره
طويله ايضا الناس لديهم تحديات وهناك
مرحله التعافي اوليه من هذه الصدمه في تلك
المناطق في سوريا الاولويه واضحه اولا
الابقاء على المعابر الحدوديه مفتوحه
والوصول غير المعرقل للمساعدات الانسانيه
عبر الحدود هناك مرور
تجاري ولكن هناك تهديدات
للمساعدات الانسانيه نحن نتطلع الى مجلس
الامن الدولي شكرا لمسؤولياته على الوقف
واعتذر منك كنت معنا من عمان الرئيس
والمدير التنفيذي للجنه لانقاذ الدوليه
البريطاني
بهذا ننهي الحصاد هذه الليله تصبحون على
خير
[موسيقى]